E aí
[Música]
há um ano novo não é
E aí
[Música]
e já é
E aí
e para poder pagar a
e pra poder falar outra passar a
E aí
[Música]
e vamos para poder pagar Fala aí
é sobre era brasileiro não é
[Música]
E aí
tá na cara né
[Música]
se alguém no caso casa provavelmente já
roupa inteira no quarto onde comer em
E aí
com a volta de você abre a
a lembrar-me
o tipo gritei aí
tô aqui no quarto inversamente aposto
Mas pode mudar a voz para mim
E aí
em São Gotardo a
quem não sabe que é
[Música]
Ah tá levitar um
E aí
[Música]
e não quer abrir não
E aí
[Música]
a frase é
E aí
eu não quero lavadores é
[Música]
E aí
a ver não
[Música]
a mata outro o olho nu falamos aqui ó
E aí
[Música]
e o óleo alguma aqui vai lá
E aí
[Música]
e talvez lá ai ai
eu falo tapo o
o Asa em
e o óleo e
e os Talvez um
E ai ai
E aí
[Música]
é um povo a lutar por ti
E aí
[Música]
e não podendo a
E aí
e por dentro do Meio 19
e vamos encontro da vó e
[Música]
E aí
é uma coisa o que é
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a página 1
se alguém aqui ó ó
E aí